Ready?
yeah. You good? okay.
While we were shooting Swagger,
the world changed.
In 2020 people really started to lean in
and ask themselves
why there's certain things in the country
that happen in the way that they do,
that they've been happening for such a long time.
There was a lot of social issues that
arose during the pandemic.
when things pause and things shut down and the
social issues came into play
Reggie put those at the forefront
because they were things that he wanted to show
that we weren't scared to talk about
I can't breathe, I can't breathe, I can't breathe
I really
had to ask myself, ya know, do I wanna deal with this?
but it just really occurred to me that this was another
opportunity to hold a mirror up to, to society
The ability to add current events into a s how
to make them more more powerful ya know,
they hit a little closer to home
the stuff that goes on in our every day lives,
we need to see,
even though it's a tough conversations to have
What we speak on in the show
are things that young people are
going through all over the country
that are unseen and it will mold you or it will break you
Our kids go out of town and are confronted by racism.
Something wrong, officers?
We got a call about a disturbance
We're just a basketball team on the way to our game
We're gonna need to see some ID
No matter if you're a star basketball player
or you work a regular job, that stuff may happen to you
We wanted to see what would happen
if they had different points of view about how to address
the issue
What would you want me to do? Brawl wit em?
We shoulda told them that we weren't scared.
I was scared.
Now are we allowed to in this country
still have different points of view and still be American?
What happens if someone takes a knee during the flag
and other people have different points of view?
Are we allowed to love this country and challenge it?
What does it matter?
It matters No it doesn't
I'm talkin 'bout brotherhood
If I kneel,
if I stand.
It's not gonna change how you all see me.
Or how you all treat me.
Reggie put into us a responsibility as performers
to be a voice for the voiceless
and uh to inspire people to be better
If people can't hear you,
you can't change them.
They weren't tryin to hear us.
Scream loud enough and they will hear us.
Scream loud enough and they'll hear 6'4" & black
I think what we did was right
when we wrote all of that into the series and
cuz this is a dialogue that we need to have as a country
to speak on
things like police brutality or the pandemic in general
and how it affected people
it makes what you're doing honorable
inspiration is the most powerful thing
that we got on the planet.
In this day in age,
in this time
what it means to grow up Black in America
Is a question that we need to ask
and I think our show will not give all the answers but
ideally it'll provoke the right questions
I wanna get the audience at the edge of their seat
and while they're leaning forward, hit em with the truth.